all right Dominic
Dominic uh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally originally from West
Virginia I um what part uh Berkeley
Springs we had a uh we had a house up
there my mom my dad
uh my dad was handicapped fully
handicapped
um he had one whole side of his body
paralyzed uh my mom was the main
supporter in our family
she was a cook for a restaurant named
kufant in West Virginia
she uh is this Western West Virginia
uh it's near Berkeley Springs Winchester
past that area it's DC area basically
okay yeah going past DC and West
Virginia area the other part of the
state yeah other part of the state
um and we uh mainly as kids we grew up
as uh poor people
um
we grew up as uh our neighborhood would
uh give us food it was uh pretty
embarrassing
we had a bunch of friends that would
bring us food my uncle uh would bring us
food to bring Us toys and when we seen
him we knew he was getting ready to have
some toys or or clothes shoes
and um you know we just kind of grew up
as kids in West Virginia and uh it was a
it was a rough time but uh we kind of
got through it and uh started growing up
um after we had moved from West Virginia
because my mother couldn't afford to
keep the house
um we uh we moved to Fairfax Virginia
um
there my brother older half stepbrother
moved in with us
um we
his name was Porky we called him William
Neal he had a uh another father he had
the same mother
and uh
we grew up with him uh being my brother
and daughter Porky or you call them
Williams yeah I called him Porky his
friends called him Porky he uh kind of
chubby a little bit
um that's a hell of a nickname yeah yeah
it's uh I think he got that from uh
Henry's wrecker service out there in
Fairfax gave him the name because he ate
all the time and uh
you know then he started growing up we
uh we smoked a lot of weed back there
back in the day and um
my brother ended up you know getting me
into smoking weed and uh
we uh started smoking weed from there
and then
uh kind of one night my brother called
me up to his little place that he had
built on my own property and uh
he uh he had some cocaine
and uh
started snorting it snorting it and you
know days went through and then he
finally offered me some and I kind of
took it
um so I was snorting cocaine at
14 years old
um so do you feel like weed was a
Gateway huh you feel like weed was a
Gateway for you yeah wheat is a gateway
drug uh you know
the way they you know give out weed
nowadays is just kind of ridiculous uh
but the way the you know the way you
open the door for weed is exactly the
same way you open the door for cocaine
yes yes and cocaine but all the other
drugs I never had a urge for
um cocaine is different it is a uh is a
drug that pulls you but
most people can't handle cocaine or
crack or heroin all that stuff they go
berserk
me I can do cocaine have money in my
pocket and go home and still have money
in my pocket the next day so mainly did
cocaine and start smoking crack uh at
the age of 16.
and uh that's when my brother found out
that it was being cooked
and so he kind of got me smoking crack
as well
um
I love my brother but uh you know he was
sort of a bad influence on me wasn't
any kind of you know hurtful person you
know he was always caring and stuff like
that but he did a lot of drugs
you know so from there uh my dad had
passed away I'd went to prison at
like age of 19.
and it was for a
a gun charge that I'd had I was drunk
one night
and uh fired a uh SKS in Fairfax
City
and that was kind of the wrong thing to
do they uh SWAT team the whole area
found where the gunshots were coming
from wasn't shooting at nobody but I was
just drunk and up late and somebody
knocked on the door they didn't want to
say who it was so I opened the door with
a gun in my hand like an idiot
um
I was so drunk that I fired the gun up
in the air and uh
almost hurt my sister that's that was
out the front door
the shells were ejecting from the gun
and hit her in the face because I was
not knowing what I was doing
but went to prison for that did
five years almost six years off that
um
then I got I got my uh
I got my second gun charge
um
after that probably
three years after that
it was my buddy's gun and we were
shooting old computer screens on a
military base
because he had military clearance to go
in there and go to the gun range so we
decided to go to the gun range one day
and
of course the gun range was packed so
full that uh every military person in
the world was there
firing their weapons and testing them
and practice practicing and stuff like
that
um
so we went to an old area
in the in the neighborhood and we got
beer and we were sitting there drinking
so we decided to shoot computer screens
so he had a little 22 shot gun low eight
shot 22.
we uh
we start shooting computer screens next
thing we know we see a uh a military guy
was in the next field and he was fine
flying his little model airplane over us
and kind of diving into us to I guess to
make us leave I don't know what he was
doing but he was in the next field and
uh so after the second time that he had
uh aimed his little plane at us I took a
shot at his flame his little remote
control plane
and uh I ended up hitting it it crashed
to the ground
not five minutes later 20 mil military
police came down on us dogs
kind of arrested US gave us 21 charges
before we got back to the to the
barracks
ended up costing my buddy a lot of money
over sixty thousand dollars to get out
of it
um
of course nowadays you can pay for just
about anything so you know if you got
enough money you can pay anything
anybody to do whatever you want in this
country
um you know
then from there I went to prison again
for the second charge
um
never really went to school I was a kind
of a person who never liked to read
um
I was a I was a bad reader still am
I uh
grew up kind of
hoping that I could read and get better
reading and I've tried in my lifetime to
read a book and and sit back and and try
to enjoy life but life is not easy
nowadays so it kind of
messed me up in the head you know not
mentally or anything just it's kind of a
thing that you live with
and uh so I started uh after I kind of
got out of prison I started to uh
you know try to behave and do the right
thing
um
I got uh got me a job and and uh
construction driving heavy equipment
um then I uh I started seeing girls and
and all this good stuff and had a
girlfriend and her name was Jackie
beautiful little Asian girl
and um
I loved her for a long time and then her
brother was real racist and did not like
white people dating a Korean woman
and so one night he had split my head
open with a brick
and I've got the scar here to prove it
he had come over the corner of the wall
and just hit me dead blind in the back
in the back of the head on top of the
head with a brick and it almost killed
me
I was down in a ditch
and I had to crawl up to the main road
to
um to get help
I crawled up to the main road and passed
out police found me
um late at night after that it was like
one o'clock in the morning when they
found me blood all over me down my
clothes
um it took my wallet all my uh shoes
that he took you took my shoes he took
just about everything I had I had a
little bag he took that
um
so I ended up in the hospital and uh my
mother was real upset with this of
course she was the only supporter of our
family
um she supported us her whole life
what happened to your girlfriend's
brother well he ended up he ended up
going to uh going to jail that that
evening it was the next day actually and
uh he ended up going to jail and um his
mother had owned a restaurant out in
Maryland Virginia Maryland uh area
and uh she liked me and she liked that I
was dating Jackie she
um she came down to the hospital real
quick got Jackie and they both came to
the hospital of course my mother was
there my mother wanted nothing to do
with him didn't want him to come in the
hospital didn't want him to come in my
room
I was still unconscious at the time
uh because they gave me a bunch of
medication to soothe the pain and stuff
like that
so when I finally woke up
like a day and a half later
um
the doctor had come in and told me that
my skull was fractured
uh
completely fractured completely broken
apart up top and that they had to put
bone or whatever they put in my head
and to kind of make it go back together
they had my head all wrapped up and they
had shaved part of my hair
um but unsung
had went to jail that day and
when he went to jail his mother didn't
know he was in jail for assaulting me
trying to kill me and when he uh they
finally found out that he was in jail of
course they bonded him out I was a real
high like a million dollar Bond they had
put him on
he uh of course his mother had the had
the restaurant so she put the restaurant
up for you know his bail and he was
going to go to court anyway because he
was a kind of a you know his mom bought
him a car bought him a motorcycle
he was the older person in the family uh
and um
so ended up
my mother finally let Jackie in
and Jackie was crying and you know upset
and real upset about it and um
so her mother come in finally and we
were talking my mom was steady cussing
her out calling her a a murderer and a
killer and trying to kill her son which
is me and um
so we ended up
the cops had come in and and they were
going to ask me if I wanted to press
charges against unsung
well the district attorney had already
picked it up and they were pressing
charges anyway
so they ended up pressing charges his
mom lost the restaurant because of the
uh lawsuit and the injury to me
uh unsung got out of jail they paid
so much money it's like six hundred
thousand dollars to get him out of jail
to keep him out of jail
um
I ended up getting a settlement from
them
um and you know it went from there we Me
and Jackie had broke up and my mom told
her that she couldn't come back on the
property she wasn't allowed back on our
property at all and she told me that I
couldn't date her no more and uh you
know
that was about it for that
um we after Jackie I had met I was
working and I had met another Korean
girl
which I still love to this day her name
was missou
um and we were
real good together she was a beautiful
woman
real outspoken
but she had a money problem she loved
money loved it
I did a lot of work
construction work I never received a
paycheck she would always get my
paycheck
I would get a hundred dollars out of a
thousand dollar paycheck
so I stuck with that for a long time
me and massu had a lot of arguments I
had a lot of contracts that I was doing
tree work
and she messed up a
fifteen thousand dollar contract for me
one time
it was for tree trimming in Virginia
and uh we had all the stuff but she kept
pulling up into the lane trying to get
money to check for every two weeks we
got paid it was
uh 15 like 15 000 we were getting paid
for every two weeks for tree trimming
along uh Virginia area and uh
she had pulled in one time and the boss
told her you know you can't come in here
you can't be pulling your vehicle in
here this is a dangerous Zone if
something drops on your uh car you know
you could get hurt and of course I come
down out of the out of the tree and told
her you know what do you want what are
you doing here why are you here
she uh she says you got the check she's
like wow you know you come down here to
get a check
and I could have gave it to you when I
got home she didn't want to wait so I
ended up losing the contract
um
for that
we had slept together
and uh
I'm pretty sure that masu
had HIV
and uh
this is how I contracted it through a
woman
and uh you know I've been living with
that horror all my life
it's uh painful very painful
so uh you know you're on medication for
it yes uh up here in Los Angeles it's uh
kind of hard to get medication anywhere
because they tell you to
get up come here at six o'clock in the
morning
and uh fill out this booklet of
paperwork and uh
you know it's uh it's hard because you
can't get up you can't uh because you
don't have the time up here
people that are homeless up here do not
really carry cell phones they carry them
but they destroy them
or they don't care about getting up
trying to find work uh me I'm Different
I like to work
I'm interested in getting a job up here
um interested in seeing the world what
made you come to Los Angeles huh what
made you come to LA
well I was here before and
um
the the money is higher up here as far
as pay so it's the cost of living though
yeah it's it's it's uh you know I have a
I have a driver's license right now I
have um I have you know social security
card I had a birth certificate but it
got mangled in my wallet this is what
I'm waiting on right now to uh to get
further work uh but right now I've been
up here just kind of
Cannon and trying to survive
but I come up to Los Angeles mainly to
try to get a better job of Virginia is
limited on what jobs you can get because
they're all gone Virginia
there's hardly no work up there
everybody's undercutting everybody
everybody's uh you know doing work
mowing the grass for five times less
than it usually is and uh it uh
it just Virginia wasn't working for me
anymore
so I've been up here before so I decided
to come back here and try to make
something better for myself trying to
rebuild your life huh trying to rebuild
your life trying to rebuild my life yes
that's uh that's exactly what exact
words I was looking for um but you're
still in love with the second Korean
woman yeah I will always love her
because she was uh taking all your money
and giving you AIDS yeah she took all my
money but uh she was a
she was very very nice woman when she
wanted to be
um
I have bad anger issues so
you know I don't know what it is but
when you give somebody some money and
then you don't get any of it back to do
anything with to buy cigarettes or buy a
drink even put gas in your vehicle you
know give her a thousand dollars in one
week and she says if you've got no money
you're you have to walk to work so I've
never walked to work but uh you know
that's how it makes you fall in love
with them it makes you fall in love with
them yeah it's kind of uh kind of crazy
I guess uh you know a woman like that uh
the whole dominatrix thing is all about
yeah I guess that's probably what it was
about I don't think you're as weird as
you you appear
but uh you know we ended up um ended up
catching that problem from her and uh by
sex
and um she uh
she uh you know kind of left me and uh
went somewhere where the money's better
um
I have a uh I have a sister that I love
dearly she never told you that she had
HIV no no no she never told me she just
uh you think she was running running a
house and I actually rented a room from
her one day and I was coming home from
work and I was all hot sweaty this is
back in the day when I was a little
younger and uh I always wore my shirt
off and I was a lot more muscular than I
am now and uh her room was right here
and my room was here
so
I walked up to my room to put the key in
and I looked over and she has a big
mirror in her room
so I'm looking over and she's standing
in her shower in her bathroom
naked and I almost couldn't take my eyes
off her because she was so beautiful
um
and then that night she knocked on my
door
and kind of just walked in and flipped
the shoes off and jumped on my bed
um
that night we had sex had a lot of sex
and um
we had uh
we had sex for hours and days I had a
job laying pipe and uh yes you did yeah
and I was uh I was absent for three days
I run a piece of heavy equipment to get
gravel and pipe sewage pipe and uh I
come back in three days later and my
boss told me says uh since where you
been I told him I said bud I've been
having the best sex of my life he says
well he said the office wants to see you
and it's not good news
so I went into the office the same day
and uh he just told me he says you know
I can't have you not coming in
not uh not showing up I know sex is fun
and good but job is kind of more
important right now
and I told him I said Bob please don't
fire me he's like man I gotta fire you
and he fired me so I went home and I
told her I said well I said I got fired
because we had sex for three days
straight
and she says oh it's okay it's okay you
find another job so
um this lady had money masu had money
when I first met her and why she offered
to buy me a Hummer when I first met her
and she had the money
of course I turned it down because I
wasn't getting into all that it was uh
you know she says oh you look so good
with a Hummer driving a Hummer like it's
just too expensive so I ended up buying
an old ratty truck and uh
you know so she offered to buy you a
Truck Yeah buy me a brand new Hummer
back in the day a couple about 10 years
ago but yeah so she's not all bad no she
wasn't all bad uh but she didn't tell
you that she had yeah her mother her
mother was was a real nice lady
um her her family was nice they used to
you know
um take me out to eat take me to drink
uh you know they never liked me smoking
weed around him but soon never liked me
smoking weed around her either but uh I
had um
I smoked weed around her brothers her
brothers love me
um even the youngest one ended up
smoking weed with me one day he was out
on a job site and I told him that I had
to go take a quick break he's like what
are you gonna do smoke me a little weed
and because I work better when I'm when
I smoke a little weed I get moving
pretty fast
we were doing siding at the time me as a
tape measure using a tape measure was
hard for me because I really had
problems uh
trying to measure but uh he uh ended up
smoking weed with me that day in the
truck
uh his sister found out my girlfriend
she found out that I gave him weed and
that day
she had took my whole stash and threw it
in the trash because she didn't want me
smoking weed with her with her brothers
and she didn't want her brother smoking
weed at all so she took my whole my bong
my bowls all my stuff that I had to
smoke weed with
took a throw in the trash and
pretty much destroyed it
uh so after masu something about a
hard-headed woman yeah yeah a real
hard-headed woman
um
after massu we had broken up blah blah
I had met a girl named Tina
and Tina lives in Florida
she has my son
his name is Dominic as well
never seen him that much
she has turned him against me told him I
was a bad guy and
um
you know that I basically didn't deserve
to see him that I wasn't around
it's kind of hard when you move to
Florida and
you're in Virginia and you have no
Transportation no way to see your son no
way to to to be a father
I've never got that chance in my life
and uh
she uh she took him to Florida and I
ain't seen him since and uh if you're
watching Tina you're a
I want to see my son
so uh
you know it's uh it was a hard life it
was a it's been a hard life been a hard
life a lot of hard lives you know
I've seen stuff out here in Los Angeles
that
amazes me
um
like the city of Los Angeles they're
they're hurting the homeless people here
hurting them they think giving them
pipes and and Bubbles and and stems and
all that stuff is good for them
well it's not
whoever runs this city is an idiot how
old are you now I am 48 48 now I'm um
and you've been here how long in Los
Angeles
uh a little over
like two months going on two months now
um
I'm trying to get work there is work out
here
um I've been listening to a lot of
conversations out here
um just sweeping trash out here you can
make up to twenty dollars an hour
uh you know a lot of people out here
they don't do their jobs
out here as far as cleaning the streets
up
they sit around smoke weed uh laugh and
play with each other they're out there
to make money they're to work they're
not working they are
gallivanting around smoking their little
weed talking to little friends on their
cell phones all the times
me I'm a different kind of person I
don't I don't have a cell phone not only
like cell phones I've broken so many in
my life just because they're annoying
um
I uh like I said I have an angry issue
that's one of the reasons why probably I
broke so many cell phones
if it doesn't work right for me I kind
of either get rid of it or destroy it or
something like that
um
but uh you know
my life's been okay hopefully
sometime soon I'll get a birth
certificate from my sister hopefully
she'll do it for me and she
she didn't
like me when I left Virginia because we
had gotten an argument
and uh
you know I owe some people some money
and I do want to pay them
but right now I'm struggling so I don't
have any money to spare
uh and I know I've been a mooch on my
family so this is one of the other
reasons why I moved out here
um what's your biggest regret in your
life huh what's your biggest regret in
your life
my biggest regret is not listening to
the people
who back in the day were telling me
to act right to do what they're doing
now
sitting back relaxing with a comfortable
job having
somebody who
loves you 24 7.
it uh it hurts you know a lot of people
out here Los Angeles they talk to
themselves it uh it's because they're
not loved and because they're not
they don't have nobody to talk to
I kind of grew up my dad was handicapped
uh like I said
you know he couldn't really talk to you
in conversation but he could say hello
hi I love you all that good stuff my dad
was a was a beautiful man my mom she was
always tired she wasn't cooking and
cleaning for us she was cooking cleaning
for somebody else
um
but yeah my biggest regret is not it's
not listening to the people back in the
day that
told me to do the right thing and to do
it now
it's not too late now but I'm still
gonna try
um I'm still going to
to try to get money in my pocket a place
to live
uh
and I am getting older and uh you know
me not uh taking my medication at the
right times or even taking my medication
does hurt me
um so I'm trying to do all that trying
to get everything straightened out
medication for what
for the HIV
yeah it's uh
it's called Big tarvy it's uh how does
it affect you if you don't take it
well I don't know
um I just don't know I know what makes
your T cells go down
um you know they don't have the
technology or the the know the knowledge
to give to all the people they don't
have that you know they're not out
preaching that they are out preaching
for you know for cancer for for uh
testing for HIV they're they're
they're just not out there doing the
right things as far as that disease that
disease can be controlled and
I probably still am undetectable
this means that I can pretty much have
sex
you know and not give it to nobody I
don't have sex with
without a condom but uh I uh you know
I just yeah that's that's basically what
that is
um
but Dominic what would you say is the
most important lesson you've learned in
your life
you've been through a lot
I'm gonna say that lesson in my life is
to to be kind not to be not to be an
uh
it's always a good one huh that's always
a good lesson yeah I've uh you know I've
I've been I've been hard-headed and
stubborn
um so I'm trying to get my stubbornness
out of me
um real stubborn
um I do swallow my pride a lot
and uh like I said I have very very bad
anger issues that I'm still coping with
and uh you know I just I'm trying to get
everything straightened out and I want
to get everything straightened out
um
the help out here
it's paperwork if you have
hours and hours and hours and days to do
paperwork they'll give you anything you
want out here
but paperwork is is a lot of annoyance
to me and it's it
it hurts you know it hurts when you have
a reading problem and it hurts when you
look at a piece of paper and you say
well what am I supposed to do with this
I had my sister
um
Pia used to do a lot of paperwork for me
a lot of computer work
um
she still does I'm sure she's getting my
birth certificate I'm hoping and praying
so I can try to start something new out
here
and uh you know
hopefully that's what what goes on
all right Dominic thank you so much for
sharing your story
you're welcome I wish you lots of luck
out here in L.A thank you very much
thank you